ok let's get into some of the flavor of
this new Trump Republican tax bill not
from the point of view of a policy
analysis which we did at the beginning
of the show but just in terms of some of
the characters the clueless characters
that voted for this now it's no surprise
to you and we've already talked about
how some elected officials didn't read
the bill but voted for it anyway and
some of them said well I got a summary
from the leadership of my party others
saying my staff summarized it for me
others saying I looked at a few pages of
it whatever what's stunning though is
the basic level of detail about which
many of these Republican lawmakers that
voted for the bill and love the bill are
totally clueless about something as
basic as the tax brackets there are only
a few tax brackets and the changing of
the tax brackets in this bill one of the
biggest elements of the bill no question
about it
huffington post went to some republicans
and said simply what are the tax
brackets in this bill that you voted for
and almost none of them could name it
now i'm not involved in this bill at all
but offhand i can tell you just from
doing stories about taxes that the
federal tax brackets before this bill
were 10 15 25 28 33 35 and thirty nine
point six i just know that offhand now
i've not tried to memorize it i don't
have a particularly good memory but we
talk about taxes enough you know once
every couple weeks normally more since
this tax bill has been on the table that
I sort of have integrated and
assimilated that data into my mind
naturally these people have been working
on this bill for months they're
supposedly dealing with it every day
most days and many didn't even know the
tax brackets we've now learned that the
brackets are 10 12 20 to 24 30 to 35 and
37 18 Republicans were asked what are
the tax brackets none were able to name
the new income tax brackets that they
were creating that they were voting for
the 19th person that they spoke to
Congressman Chris Stewart he knew I
guess although he also says something
weird in the clip right he says let's
listen to it even the lead author of the
house
version of the bill this is his bill
right Kevin Brady even he couldn't name
all of the tax brackets what on earth is
going on here here are some of the
interviews that Huffington Post it
wondering how familiar you think
everyone is with this tax bill you guys
are passing today
ton of times read it we've had several
weeks I read it on the plane two weeks
in a row okay do you know what the
brackets are on this bill this is an
amazing building to help the entire
country especially the middle class in
my district but you know that I got to
run the votes do you know in the
brackets on the top so you don't know
yeah so it went on and on and on and
finally they got to a guy who was able
to name them even though I think he said
that zero is one of the brackets which
according to my reading there's no zero
bracket unless your income is zero
because yeah exactly because then you'd
have eight brackets right but I guess if
you make zero dollars you're paying zero
percent that would be a way to pay zero
percent taxes yeah but no up until I
think it's ninety two hundred or so
dollars you do pay ten percent federal
income tax on that it is an
embarrassment yeah I think he had
interviewed twelve or so Republicans so
when he found one that got almost all of
it right I think he just went with that
yeah that was number 19 the 19th guy
interviewed 18 none of them knew it and
then the 19th guy was able to say I hear
hero what the tax brackets are the
embarrassment is that they there's sort
of two ways to interpret this right one
interpretation would be they don't
really care enough about the brackets
even though it's a huge consequence to
everyday Americans to have even
integrated that information because they
didn't really spend that much time on it
that that's sort of one possibility the
other possibility is that these people
are just so disconnected from the work
that they're doing and maybe even
incompetent that they don't integrate
even these most basic facts into their
mind after months of working on this
link the original House bill had only
four brackets yeah but I mean it's been
week since then and this is the major
thing that you're pushing for no excuse
I think you should memorize it at least
the lowest and the highest numbers and
and even if it's not a question of we
know it's not going to impact them right
they they're not going to be impacted by
where the cutoff is between the 15 and
22 percent bracket or whatever tax
bracket
there are but at least make it appear as
though you really care how the average
taxpayer is going to be impacted by
these changes that you're making
absolutely and utterly pathetic they
just didn't read it most of them did not
read it and that's something that we
should all be really really concerned
about you can discuss this with us on
our subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di t today's program is sponsored
by live lingua we're getting down to the
end of the end-of-the-year holiday
gift-giving season and if you're
thinking about getting your relatives
yet another kitchen gadget or another
pair of boring socks consider giving the
gift of language live lingua uses a
program a method of direct full
immersion with native speakers of the 11
most widely spoken languages in the
world and this is something that people
will actually use your friends and
family will appreciate this and there's
no gimmicks right Live Ling was not
going to tell you using our website for
5 minutes a day you'll be fluent in a
month right what they will tell you is
that they use the exact same approach
that diplomats and educators have used
for hundreds of years but they do it
online giving students the opportunity
to build routine and actually stay in a
comfort zone that will work for them and
be the best possible thing for their
learning of the language ok you can this
holiday season take advantage of the
live lingual gift card discount and free
trial lesson at live lingua kaam slash
Pakman and you don't have to give it as
a gift to someone else if you decide to
use the gift card on yourself and to
take the free first lesson yourself live
lingual won't say anything as long as
you go to live lingua Calm slash Pakman